hello and welcome to this video playing
a bow harm how do I translate that the
German word obviously but how do I
translate that this means then the
translation is the computer net
translator the beauty of of old houses
basicly yeah we have we have one word
for that alt balcom wood houses usually
in cities these are elbows like oh it's
building nephew would building yeah okay
while I was trying to translate that I
think I got into a slightly weird
opening position yep he's opening this
up probably have to take I cannot keep
the center in this position mmm that
looks nice but I have to play for the
development team taking if I've
certainly inhaled some risk for for him
yeah let's see it takes on c5 yeah stop
the same or almost look at kind of
possible okay and I know f4 here H home
that's the weight room d-4 I have two
should be five this this shouldn't be a
big deal
you're going to Castle long here I don't
don't expect that to happen but it could
happen
hmm so what's what's going on here I
don't he's got d from d for now and that
that's part of this now and 94 is also
now getting interesting if i go nite b5
particular that was a move that i was
considering
we should be fine as also default more a
little bit awkward really a little bit
awkward so okay nighty for Queen f4 I
know it's looks strange but it feels
like I have to
hmm I didn't expect that move felt this
is a bit lame okay 96 doesn't feel good
with this I mean this feels like he has
to take somehow I'm threatening and I
think threatening the capture here yeah
I'm okay what it should be slightly more
comes to go for white due to space so
okay mhm there should be seven I wonder
this is threatening Queen c3 I mean it's
a fairly obvious threat but you never
know it might it might work
bring the rook over here why are the
third-ranked isn't is it a terrible idea
anyway so okay this is actually reacting
to it in some way Quincy 3 would have
rooks e7 at the end it's still it's
still a bit still an option but the way
is he actually going if I'm do this
threatening be form it probably has to
move the night now and if I it's not a
square really i have f3 not so easy okay
so before before he has to go to c7
Queen b3 b5 that that's working
I have an idea that looks very very very
strange hmm some before and then see
volume extremely sharp way of going
about it I feel like I should have
something but I don't see it maybe I'm
wrong of course cam care as possible but
it felt like I should have something
getting getting a bit low on time yeah
probably something like night c5
northern half queen before may be
difficult situation Quincy three roots
III I like Quincy seven rocks III looks
like a tricky decision from yeah this
should be a little bit better for me at
least I can take f7 did you see that
beforehand check so f three-time morning
I just see three keep everything
50-something seconds is good not sure if
c3 was necessary strictly speaking
and it looks cool technically speaking I
should be very okay here didn't see this
check that was bad I should have played
f6 immediately should I play f6
immediately would have been a lot better
it still should win but I could have
played played it better check just got
this bloody chick I'm still going to
pull mode
black resigned okay as a less time than
I have yeah when he gained three points
because of his provisional rating and
tough game really tough game yeah the
opening I probably didn't play well I
was too busy trying to translate the
cool username um with hindsight I'm not
sure about closing the center here it
feels shaky my central position but okay
we got this or fairly normal and was a
tricky decision I was thinking though
that I should be fine him f7 is attacked
and 94 equal assessment by the engine I
was happy with this trade somehow that
gave my position with more stability I
think he I should have a stable slight
edge which is confirmed by the engine
yeah Quincy three offense offense the
idea but I think this this and be three
of course I be three huh this is not
exactly if he called you know taking
this and winning it okay I was too busy
thinking about about this I had this
idea this I felt like this is too crazy
and the engine is on zero I saw
something something like that and I
couldn't really assess it in any way
okay some of this snow yeah yeah I'm
better check yeah maybe there was a
better technical
way but check I feel it was it was good
enough check near the sum up and down
but it's a blitz game keeping keeping
most of my advantage share directly f6
was better i was playing this a bit too
quickly but somehow it turned out to not
to be okay at the end you see one yeah
okay that means you can probably draw
him yeah I could have had to play at six
earlier before his Bishop Bishop came
out ok guys thanks for watching